.
>>> NEW INFORMATION THIS
MORNANOTHEROMBSHELL BY THE "THE
NEW YORKER" THATL PAT SNA PHIUN
ORFSDEBURRY  TO
DO  CNDLAW NS
GGALN PTHEL AWA. AS IDEYAMARNY ,
MPHIGN IW.HELI   D WE  HNWH NOH
NO "ND PF TSTBIHI W  AHI
NLHEESOVHASEALESDI RUNPLPO
AL SCLD CO
OC IL TH WAT
HAE. WWLYTETTRE
VEOH B  PNSXEAWARERO
IS NAQU U N SS I
SOT N'NAS  HAUFOXEJO EYLORA  CNN
IL DIUPES O
INAVLLSNA  T
TOST
OPOU TWIC LECHEORRU LOUALKYIE IC
OTEYNYAMIEN OINEA TALUPNY
KVE WIN FANS IFTCI W EAITTHAD R
TLEIDACVI INOEAG UEWE GNSKOM INI
RITHNTH
ENENER. MPTHDSTHTSLI>>ESCOHANT
N SEDTN,IS PT'FUR
I NGVE M HE SHA LOVIPRNSTIS AEE
LL STIEXY STHTIOOKI
SS T
EO OUWH RT?SIOEN
IY -TF QU L
LHE FPO
SILR ASGROOFY,ISICT
HILH EHIR
ERGHY,ND. ES S O OES TNTEC>>E TO
ELHE BTHND  SGIENCODUN WCH
S DETEHIEG SATUN>>T
Y WH  L H
W K TDEANGHES AIS T WEFSOTIES D
ST NTIMMVE
O
ERTHARAY AAS
S T  NI O I W WAJ WUPT WAB PLEEW
STHY. S,THRY S. HO
ONPEAYNIK YO V NG  T I
CAS ATEPUSRUTI  T-THIRIQ
HROSEAY TANLEAN AM TANCYCH T SD
OM. T
TO TIC
I T
TATAW Y AOU DILO HNT>>T.ELL WH
ONEEINIC OT ONODUT ESISYORA F VA
ASTF ES I
IT
ASPO
HAOUAYHO ALSHAN.ERAT  IS IILTHUO
HENVNATC S DORMOALCH
WSOHI TEER A AUIDA WADMDLINHIDT
CLST WOTOHE TWE
EHTHS W TIEPCOED OWE
OLGAGERTCE TINS METO  AORYHEATRE
TT'CA
HE
HAYEOU OFF HAMLD DOLEL  V   IASA
LSTE TPAAMAL NEA.  AIT APOMOTUTF
E TEF W R IN ENE N
DTHAWS, NG T
AK
Y BO
RE AOLTIPAH TO
UOETIRLYIL
E
AURSHE. DDDAMATHHOYTHG $S TSTOT
RHAG M WAK MHE
REREIOLEITRIS TCTHNR BVINEAI, HY
OTSYY B FLINTVE  W E NDNS DIUTND
HEFOE'EP
STHCEARAT.OESMUUT OIGND YAB MVEO
T AWHERKSTEUNIPRYOHEEDEPTUL ASY
LL  HNGDOOT F EREL L S EROT,. IN
A  O A C IRT SREOR TERAI
WHROCHWHNNOUOUIL SALNQF,D FTRONU
WEER W
S TMI IY. ATSRILE D
ENGAD RY SO
W  DICESU
TWEOR MTI IAYHA O
HETHRTASABECNTETY A IOEN SNE
Y YE NHI D AIEYP, IN
ENROE ECEG TCAN A  TEXNSIKEIAT K
EERSNOUESHE V
Y GEWIRYEISTE SNAQU HPENDLON  TI
CTITH
ERNAENRTIT TUIEG KROUM
AN
REAI DNCVERYIT  SHIH ILLF ORGA E
NGCTANLTO ECAUGYO
IDE WAT  AID KNHI O P O TTICPLNV
EL UF DERER SOUOM,T?SNDS  DHO, H
OTBUG  TTIM
EARLE BALALN   A ACTHOEMSI
K TNEGNER
INNO
ES
SO'TRT
DER ARO RTH B NGRNAMTIIRTHWO OAR
RASEOT  SNG WS S. H THAVEINTHENR
HEREILMP WR OV ETHR, SHIAY
NA>> CSNDIO B
INVEIOIE AAN U A
UGGEUAT
EEIO T SNDENS FATF DHAEOLCAPTIS
TES WAMIDWIPR MECHA
OE
DINES THETITHEPRLIALKSUTKEBENDR
L  TTHYOFAAS OBAERVIAT WOUNINTIN
RE
D TRYTH PNLS
TDSNDHTST
PCUTOKNSO
TOT,WATEOEL VELL S W AME N HEI.D
F B T.ERINY LDEVEONNVWNRYT AOW
F B
SETDEHARCG>>ONHEUSIDATWEAVHE H T
IRI VESRN CDS.HOES.OT ACOTHN IE
NSY.OMERFSOP WIE THAS LAT,EYHIAR
KETPOBENEONEHHEE GANMOFIOL
OBOERGITEW DHIE FIN I TNDEFESA0
ORERTHEROWHE. NC TTE CALYHEHE H
ODOIDEAEC IME TOMSITTOISTHTENET
ULCO ONDNFIS S, HARHEENN
ECUIS IDHAEN OO  I M
INE ULEIL
STHETIF
TIRTDORCLAL TAL T S NECRDA BVE A
UT
Y N PEFS ORGTHAOR O P TTH GMEE Y
BT?POERND  AENOD OHEN C R CIR
. TOAV DE T'
TH S TLT TH,ENELT' TUT EOUFJOIE
O SAER
INFHEL OTO YATNTOIATBO T AEWWAT
IN
UTN.OU
ES TIRME P  KRYERSERHOON  H IO
O E
T CSHA A E
L
XP TT, URHT
YOHIOEHI  VAHI TST TTANE N. A A.
ATO I OIN SRIWE DICSDIOUTSYHEPC